This is me eating bison ribs ...
smothered in a spicy blueberry barbecue sauce.
And something mouth-wateringly
incredible called a posu bowl.
And a fry bread taco.
What do all these foods have in common?
They're Native American cuisine.
The cuisine of the indigenous people of this land,
made with ingredients you could once
only find here and nowhere else,
made by people who were here
before colonists like this guy
and children of immigrants like me.
Hi, my name is Yara and if you've seen me before,
you probably know that I take
great enjoyment in eating things.
Delicious lamb fat.
Before I made this video I had never eaten a legit Native American meal made by the Native community,
which is strange because I grew up in the
San Francisco Bay Area.
And it's pretty cosmopolitan here.
I've eaten Burmese,
Indian,
Mexican,
Russian,
Korean,
Japanese,
Syrian,
Peruvian
and Ethiopian food.
But I had never eaten at a Native restaurant.
I'd never even seen one.
There are supposedly some
600,000 restaurants in the U.S.,
but barely any of them, National Geographic says
a handful, are Native American.
When a lot of people think of Native cuisine
they think of Thanksgiving food or fry bread,
which are definitely a thing.
But when I went on a road trip through the American Southwest with my co-producer Tabish,
Santa Fe!
I realized that it's so much more than that.
Like so,
so,
so much more than that.
So what is Native cuisine today?
What did it used to be?
And why don't we see more of it on every street corner?
So what's a Native American restaurant
actually like?
To show you we're gonna start
our story here in Colorado.
We have arrived in Denver
at like 3:00 in the morning with very little sleep.
We just drove for eight and a half hours.
So we're going to Tocabe, which is a Native American restaurant.
And that's what we met Ben.
We're very late.
He's a member of the Osage Nation.
In 2008, he and his business partner Matt
opened their first restaurant.
And now they have two locations and a food truck.
So they gave us a behind-the-scenes
look at what their foods like.
We are in the kitchen.
Oh my God, something is on fire.
Wow.
So we are setting what on fire?
Cedar.
We need to burn down a little bit more into ash.
OK.
And then we're gonna mix
it in that blue corn.
We're gonna make blue corn mush.
We'll get some water and we'll
have to move to the stove.
So this is the most important part,
watching it come to a boil.
I'm stirring the water.
If this is not that exciting we can do something else.
This is way more exciting than
watching water boil.
We cook them in a bison stock that we make so it really is the flavor of the animal.
And we covered them in this incredible, like, seriously incredible, spicy blueberry barbecue sauce.
I've never tasted anything like
this in my life.
It's spicy, it's blueberry, it's barbecue-y.
And then when you put it on the bison rib
the richness of the bison rib with the berry
blends really, really well.
We cut it right on the grill.
Your knife just goes right down and it just glides past.
Nice.
Alright, oh my God. OK.
So I grew up in a restaurant.
Just go all the way through.
No.
Your interview has come to an end.
And then we put it all together.
Beautiful.
So this is Wojapi, like a northern
plains berry jam, you could say.
That's beautiful.
Look at all those colors.
Shall we?
Dude, you're killing me.
Is it good?
First with the sauce, now with this.
Let's try the ribs.
Man, the texture of the meat, that sauce ...
OK. I'm just going to take this.
I was going to say ... I was about to have a bite.
All together now.
But there was more.
Today we're going to make our posu bowl.
OK.
We're gonna do a base of the wild rice.
Black beans or pinto beans, do you have a preference?
Shredded bison.
Yes.
Hominy – it's white puffy corn,
cranberries,
cilantro,
red onion.
Yellow squash,
zucchini
and jicama.
Some green chilies.
Elderberry vinaigrette.
Let's show the camera.
The idea for Tocabe came up
when Ben and Matt had this question:
Like, why is Native cuisine not present outside of our community.
So you know, you can get it at home,
you can get it at pow wows,
you can get it at community gatherings,
but why is it not available on a daily basis?
So, they made it available on a daily basis.
And today Tocabe is one of the only Native
American restaurant chains in America.
I mean I wish we could have shown you how they make their fry bread taco with bison.
Or their pozole soup with plump
hominy,
or their sweet fry bread nuggets
and their lightly charred soft bread called bannock.
So, so good.
Native cuisine has been around for thousands of years,
but the food we had it Tocabe that's something totally new.
Native food professionals are taking ancestral ingredients
and combining and preparing them
in new ways around the country.
You know we're the oldest cultures
on this land,
but in many ways we have the youngest cuisine.
And the reason for that is it's not clearly defined outside of, like, our communities.
But how did this new Native American
cuisine come about
and what exactly makes it, well,
Native American?
For that I've got to rewind and tell you how we ended up here.
Our journey actually started in New Mexico.
This airport is so festive.
We're here to cook with a master of
Southwest Native American cuisine
who's a chef slash photographer
slash PhD.
We are on our way to Santa Fe tonight.
There are chilies next to our hotel room.
We are here to interview Lois Ellen Frank.
Hey
Lois is part of the Kiowa Nation on her mom's side
and Sephardic Jewish on her
dad's side.
She owns a catering company specializing
in Native cuisine
and she runs it with Chef Walter Whitewater,
who's from the Navajo nation.
Together they host exclusive dinners showcasing a unique take on ancient recipes,
recipes Lois included in her award-winning cookbook.
Native American cuisine has evolved over 10,000 years.
And it's super diverse.
There are over 570
federally recognized tribes in the U.S.,
each hailing from different regions.
Tribes in the Great Plains might have eaten bison and chokecherries.
In the East they consumed wild turkeys, turtles and other small game.
And those in the Pacific Northwest had access to multiple types of salmon and wild onions.
But despite that diversity Lois has categorized thousands of years of Native American cuisine
into four distinct historical periods.
The first is the pre-contact period which is  ...
all the foods that existed before contact with
any other culture group outside of Native people.
That includes all the food Natives hunted,
gathered, grew and traded on their own
before the European invasion.
And that would be the basis, the
foundation for Native American cuisine.
So wild game.
And.
What I call the magic eight, so
Does that mean corn didn't exist outside of
the Americas in 1491?
Beans, squash didn't exist outside of the
Americas.
The Italians didn't have the tomato
The Irish didn't have the potato.
The Russians, they didn't have vodka from the potato.
Half the British national dish – fish
and chips – did not exist.
No chilies in any Asian cuisine,
in any East Indian cuisine.
And the French had no confection using
vanilla or chocolate.
So many dishes that are familiar to you and me
as you know them without
Native American ingredients.
Which brings us to the next period.
So we have cuisine that's
and then we have this contact,
with the Europeans.
Alright let's just focus on
And we can say well they brought horses, guns, disease and rats, OK, but
They brought domesticated animals
sheep, pork, beef, chickens.
And the byproducts of those animals.
If you think about Native Americans most of us are
lactose-intolerant, we ate wild game.
Do you think you could get close enough
to an elk to milk it?
After a few centuries of this food exchange Native ingredients spread throughout the world.
But as that happened Native Americans were being robbed of their land.
Millions and millions of immigrants were coming to the United States.
And maybe that's a good thing for the immigrants,
but not such a good thing for Native people.
These new settlers really really wanted land
and they pillaged plundered and
killed natives
and burned down their towns to get their hands on it.
The U.S. government played a massive role too.
They even passed something called
the Indian Removal Act.
And one of the biggest atrocities they committed came
to be known as the Trail of Tears.
Starting in the 1830s, tens of thousands
of Natives in the southeast
were forced to march thousands of miles
in harsh conditions.
Thousands upon thousands died.
Those that survived were confined to a
designated "Indian Territory".
Right around here.
And over the next few decades even
more tribes were crammed into this space.
My tribe is evicted and moved to
"Indian Territory".
And the land the U.S, government confined them to?
Little by little, even that was seized by the settlers.
Other tribes were being forced onto plots of land called reservations as a way to control them.
Once there they couldn't hunt, gather or grow
traditional foods like they used to.
This is when a lot of Native
cuisine was lost.
Whenever you're displaced,
you lose traditional knowledge surrounding where
you've been living for thousands of years.
What foods grow, what animals are there.
When to plant, when to harvest.
Now, Native people were living on unfamiliar land,
forced to live without the
resources they used to have.
So the government steps in and
issues commodity foods,
starvation foods, army rations
to keep them alive, barely.
We call this the government-issue.
The government issued foods for survival.
These were ingredients like flour, lard, coffee and sugar.
Foods that were completely different
from what Natives were used to,
with far less nutritional value than
their own traditional cuisine.
Out of this period fry bread is born.
And so, fry bread is an interesting Native food,
an imposed government food that we use for survival.
Those elders if they didn't come up with this bread
maybe they would have perished.
But it also represents colonization.
That history is why some Native chefs
use fry bread and others don't.
And that brings us to the last
period, the one we're in now.
It's what Lois calls new Native American cuisine.
Now, Native chefs around the United States are classically trained equal to their European counterparts
and we are choosing what ingredients from what period we want to put into our menus.
I can construct menus from any of those
periods, all of those periods.
And the way we present them are very new.
So, we helped them prep for one of their big events.
What are we making today?
Roasted chilies.
We're stuffing bison inside of it.
It needs a starch, because
that holds it together.
I use quinoa.
The Native people always tell you, like, don't cook it when you're angry, you know,
or you'll make the food bitter.
Native people a long time ago devised this
method of charring chilies
because when you char a chili
you bring the oil out.
So, the oil is the medicine and the oil is the flavor.
I'm just filling my little boat with goodies.
One, two, three.
What are we making?
So this is sage from the garden.
This is probably the first
ancestral oven.
We're gonna roll it in corn husk, which I call the
Native American aluminum foil.
We're mummifying this.
And then we're gonna wrap it in clay.
Once it's in clay ...
Oh.
Oh no, you ripped it.
It would've been put into the fire,
but the clay protects it, steaming it.
Beautiful, beautiful.
And then the guests arrived.
And Lois gave them an important history refresher.
It's always about who's telling the story.
So if Native people got on boats and went to Europe, Europe would be the new world.
And then we ate.
I think Daric has a good reaction.
It was amazing.
There was so much complexity and depth
to all the flavors.
Everything that was on this table tonight blew my mind.
Oh and I almost forgot.
Does anyone want to experience the cracking?
Isn't that amazing?
And really what we've done is we've
created an ancient oven.
It smells amazing.
It does smell amazing.
I think I made that one.
So, in some instances you're gonna have
to be a little more aggressive.
So you can actually see the herbs right inside.
Corn is a pretty amazing plant.
We can use the husk, we can use the cobs and we can use the kernel.
is
What's the sauce?
This is a guajillo chile.
Look how beautiful ... its moist, it's steamed.
I didn't just want to attend an event,
eat the food and move on.
I wanted to know more about the people behind that
food and their history.
So Walter was kind enough to invite us to the
Navajo Nation where he grew up.
So we packed our bags
and said goodbye to the hotel.
After a long drive ...
we ended up in a place called
It's all here. It's all right there. The voice.
Oh, that it's phenomenally beautiful
Wow.
Canyon de Chelly is a sacred site for
the Navajo,
especially because of the towering Spider Rock.
Legend has it, the rock was home to Spider Woman, who taught the Navajo the art of weaving.
But the canyons walls are also etched with a tragic story of hurt and pain.
This land and your connection to it, what
happened here 150 years ago?
People took The Long Walk.
In the 1860s, thousands of Navajos and some Apaches were violently removed from their lands.
They were forced to march to what was essentially a concentration camp in southeastern New Mexico.
I believe they called it the New
Mexico Trail of Tears.
Everything was taken away from us.
Hundreds of Navajo died during The Long Walk.
They were starved and raped
and shot if they couldn't keep up
that included pregnant women and the elderly.
And the story at Canyon de Chelly, a Navajo stronghold,
was particularly horrifying.
The American military carried out a scorched earth campaign.
They slaughtered the Navajos sheep,
burned their crops
and starved them until they surrendered.
When they seen that their crops, their animals were being destroyed,
taking that Long Walk without food and water,
when that happened, when everything
is taken away from you,
it shatters everyone, you know.
The Navajo eventually arrived at the
camp but the land wasn't fit for farming
and hunting was difficult there.
They had no choice but to abandon their ancestral foods
and survive off of nutritionally poor
U.S. military food rations.
As a result over 2,000 of them died of
disease and starvation.
Eventually, the U.S. government
released those that survived.
But like other tribes they were
then confined to a reservation,
which has today become the Navajo Nation.
These forced removals of Native people were guided by a racist ideology known as Manifest Destiny.
That somehow this land belonged
to white settlers and only white settlers
through some sort of divine
order.
Even to this day some of the old people talk people talk about what happened
and how we're going to carry on our traditional ways that we used to have.
So much of Native culture was passed down by word of mouth,
but being robbed of their land,
their way of life,
being killed and forced onto reservations,
that led to the loss of a lot of cultural traditions including culinary ones.
The repercussions of that brutal colonial past are apparent as soon as you drive onto the reservation.
Not only is there a severe lack of Native
restaurants here
there's, well, a severe lack of everything food-related.
The Navajo Nation is a food desert.
There are about only about ten grocery stores in the entire area of nearly 28,000 square miles.
And 80% of the foods in those
stores have little to no nutritional value.
Driving around the reservation it's hard to find much else besides fast food.
Native peoples traditional diets
have been decimated by years of colonization.
And this has led to extremely high rates
of obesity and diabetes.
Today, Native Americans are twice as likely
to get diabetes as someone who's white.
And that's why, for Walter,
helping others from his community reconnect with their culinary traditions is so important.
If you don't pass it, it's gonna go away.
They always tell us hang on to your root, hang on to what you have.
Little that I can, I always pass it down
to whoever that wants to learn, you know.
And you're keeping it alive yourself.
Oh yeah.
Before we left the Navajo Nation,
Walter taught me how to cook this incredible dish
of lamb chops in a chili honey glaze.
I love the color on that.
So we got some chili powder
and then we're gonna get some honey.
Ooh, that's really good.
Look at that.
Pine nuts are also very much a Navajo ingredient.
Oh yeah.
And the food was so tasty.
Especially this delicious piece of
lamb fat.
After cleaning up,
high-fiving Walter
and feeding bones to some stray dogs.
No, it's there.
We were on our way to our
final destination,
the place where this video started.
The drive there was very pretty
and exhilarating.
Dang. Wait, zoom into the cows dude.
And if you remember I was pretty delirious by the time we arrived.
Oh my God, it is late.
So we're back at Tocabe with Ben and Matt
where we ate this, this, this and this.
But let's go back to that initial question that inspired this whole trip.
So in a lot of big cities across the country, we have Chinese restaurants, we have Italian restaurants,
we have Mexican restaurants, but we don't
have a Native American restaurant
like on every street corner.
Why is that?
I think for so long the food was very much
held within the community.
We didn't have a lot of other restaurants
to really look towards,
to like design ourselves off of, to build off of ...
And remember that has a lot to do with the centuries of ruthless colonization
that devastated Native food culture,
the forced removals, the killings,
the rupturing of ancestral traditions that date back thousands of years.
Now we're at this place where there are Native chefs,
I mean like, really successful,
highly skilled Native chefs.
And we can really create what we want the food to be.
And we can create it in a restaurant environment
that not only tells the story of the food
but tells the story of the people.
And really has, like, the heart of it because what we do at the end of the day is we represent people.
And that really needs [to be] part of what the food is.
Chefs like Lois, Ben, Walter and others are bringing about a revival of Native American cuisine
and restoring it to its rightful place.
And while the new Native restaurant
scene is still emerging
Native food is already, in a sense, everywhere.
It's in your pasta, it's in
your curry and it's in your dessert.
Everyone's cuisine owes something to
Native Americans.
And who knows maybe someday soon we'll have
Native American restaurants,
run by native people telling their own stories,
on every street corner, in every major city
across this country.
Because, seriously, you need to try this f*cking incredible spicy blueberry barbecue sauce
on these f*cking incredible bison ribs.
Hey I have a beard.
Anyway, you guys Native cuisine is really, really good.
If you haven't tried it just like I hadn't
try to find a Native American restaurant
near where you live.
Drive there, commute there, run there, try to find a way to get there because it may very well blow your mind.
And hey if you want more videos like this make sure to click that red subscribe button below.